Um, first question is this one that's just said, information on cocaxia. So this is the home page,
I just took a screenshot of the home page, this right here, of the members holy site. And um,
this is what you have access to, how you access this info right now. We've moved our, our,
all our blog that used to be on our website is now only accessible through your private
membership. So you'll be members of our, you know, our quote unquote patients that we can't use
that term anymore. This is the legal holiday, it's going on, practice some verbal medicine here.
Um, we, we pulled all our blog off of the, uh, the, the web beating the public web. So
public can't see our blog unless they do exactly the web address to get to it. Um, so it's not
on our website anymore, it's all on this site. So there's some, we're doing a lot of updates to them,
there's some, some old information, some of the blogs I wrote five, six, seven, eight years ago,
so we're going through an updated eight hundred and fifty blog posts. But we're trying to make it
relevant for you guys today. How do you get to information on cocaxia or information on,
you know, aromatase of temperatures or information on whatever you're looking for on the members
site? Go to that little thing right there. Click on it. I can't click on it. This is just a screenshot.
Click on that thing right there and then you can put it in whatever term you want and it'll take
you to somewhere on the site or the blog that has that. So if it doesn't take you to anything,
I don't have anything on it, but I have several articles like cocaxia and one things you could do
for cocaxia and healthy gain weight with your losing weight. So anything that you need to search for
start with that.